a 13 year old girl did stand-up on
America's Got Talent this week and she
killed with a Donald Trump joke check it
out my only qualification to be a
babysitter is that I used to be a baby
that's like saying Richard the host of a
reality show you'll want to be President
of the United States
[Applause]
okay so it's it's a kid you're not doing
a little joke on TV you'd think Trump
would just shrug this off but the girl
Lori Mae Hernandez of Lancaster
California she's just 13 years old all
right you think not a big deal but check
out these tweets Trump set out today all
right yeah it's unbelievable look at
this one lame Lori thinks her hacky
jokes can hurt me she's a loser and so
is Baldy Mandel teenagers then an hour
later he wrote this lame Laurie think
she can get under my skin wrong hashtag
rhinoceros hashtag skin hashtag nothing
at all then an hour later America's Got
Talent more like lame Lori's got dumb
glasses hashtag sick burn hashtag
nothing at all then crooked Hillary
should be in jail right next to lame
Laurie hashtag to Crookes hashtag
nothing at all then the show's called
America's Got Talent but lame Laurie's
last name is Hernandez who'd sure like
to see that birth certificate
not thin at all then lamb Laurie thinks
I care what she says I don't care what
she says hashtag nothing at all hashtag
not been at all
hashtag nothing at all and finally I
hereby suspend my presidential campaign
hashtag damn you lame Laurie hashtag
defeated by a child
[Applause]
you
you